introduce our next speaker that some of
you know and some of you wish you knew
because
narika had
rice and started with proof complexity
and she went to work on things that
everybody is talking about before
everybody was talking about it and
moreover she got people to talk about
them
and I
I'm sure she'll do a better drugs than I
do explaining what you've done but
that's amazing listening
thank you very much can you hear me
can you hear very well yeah can you turn
it on okay thank you
so I'm so honored to have the
opportunity to speak at this Workshop
self lighting the 60th birthday of my
dear friend Tony pitasi can you see me
throughout her career then he has been a
dedicated and inspiring teacher mentor
and Scholar
a commitment to academic excellence and
her passion for her field of research
have inspired countless students and
colleagues over the years but perhaps
most importantly
honey has been a true leader in her
field blazing a trail for women and
minorities in Academia
a commitment to diversity and inclusion
has been a Hallmark of her career and
her tireless effort to promote equity
and fairness have inspired us all
our friendship began in 1998 when we met
during a special year of proof
complexity at the fields Institute led
by Steve Cook
Alan burden
Faith Allen Terry lackov and of course
Alastair cart and Tony were there in
Toronto
and Maria Benet
ramras cesaras baraf Alan words and of
course happy rickersonjoined it was
truly wonderful moment in my life
so today
I'd like to talk about my thoughts on
proof complexity from my point of view
before I start my talk
I would like to ask you one question
it doesn't work
it does move for some reason okay I see
okay let's do this what is your favorite
theorem
I forgot to ask attorney for her
favorite term was
we were so busy with talking about good
food like sushi and cooking because both
of us love cooking so that means we chat
a lot about good food and again good
food so we didn't have enough time to
discuss with each other what our
favorite terms were
my favorite term is
genson's cut elimination theorem
no hesitation absolutely
let me briefly introduce you to canton's
sequence calculus LK
a finite sequence of farmers is called
accident
can be empty
two students connected by an error are
called a sequence
comes to the left of the error are
interpreted as ends and those to the
right as ores
here's an example of a sequence
in textbooks
LK is introduced as a system that starts
with an initial segment
of the form a arrow a and constructs
proof of a theorem by applying left or
right logical rules
let us consider in reverse
first write the theorem you want to
prove at the bottom
then by applying logical rules to the
outermost logical symbol of the
outermost formulas of the sequence in
backwards
put that A1
in this sequence is of the form
a or C in this case the outermost
logical symbol of the leftmost formula
is or
so two upper sequence were generated
the number of logical symbols in a and C
in Upper sequence
is at least one less than that in AOC
in the lower sequence
if all paths lead to the initial
sequence you can complete the proof
without any Talent
however
that's right okay
has an influence rule called cut this is
the only one that does not predict the
upper sequence from the lower sequence
in other words
you need talent to come up with an
appropriate cut formula X
but be glad
hats are removable
this is a Contin
unlike many of you here today
I was not very good at math until I
graduated from high school
in college I majored in law and later
switched to mathematical logic
so perhaps I have been so fascinated by
the continuation theorem which suggests
the possibility of writing proofs
without Talent
however it is not all good
when cuts are eliminated
proves almost always explode
exponentially or super exponentially
so Frank George bolos wrote in his essay
don't eliminate Cuts he had a good
reason
by the way I said almost always right
so what is exception
Tony Aleister and I discussed exception
in our stock paper the propositional
logic version of LK Limited in the
conjunction in conjunctive normal form
uh with without without cut is almost
equivalent to the analytic Tableau right
on the other hand a system of LK will
admit cuts of course you know limited to
CNF formulas is almost equivalent to
resolution
we have shown that dollar is only a
quasi polynomial gap between the two
as far as I know
that is probably the only exception if
you know other exceptions please let me
know by email
and this means the proof without cut in
order in other words the proof without
Talent takes a tremendous amount of time
it seems that Bell is a Trader between
talents and time it takes to prove
and I think this is exactly why the
proof complexity is all about
that is my point of view okay regret
less of quite below sets I could not
give up the hope of writing proofs
without Talent
the think about
about this you know the possibility
probably it requires some preliminary
studies
so the first order predicate logic as we
learn in logic 101 is complete
it was proved by ghetto in 1929
also be proved you know kind of
utilizing lk's cut elimination theorem
method
however
it is not decidable
there is more bad news
piano arithmetic is incomplete
not only the original piano arithmetic
but any essential arithmetic subsystems
like S12 by bus
Summer Bus the any you know essential
arithmetic subsystems which allows gadle
numbering is all incomplete
that is very sad
however
there are some good news
positive result the net as well as well
known as ghetto's incomplete Nephilim
there are some decidable theories yes
these results are mainly due to Alfred
polsky
while many of this decidable theories
may not appeal to professional
mathematicians
uh the LA also interesting theories in
which Rich mathematics can be developed
a typical example is the theory of real
close fields I think
and I will come back later how it is
interesting
to some systems are incomplete while
some others are decidable
this means that when we are asked to
prove why
how much talent is required depends on
the context not only the the you know
the
what the why is but it really depends on
context
let me you know consider this the next
problem this one prove the following
can you see the formula okay can you
solve it
at first glance many people may think it
is a theorem of real numbers
but if you try to think why there is X
cubed y plus Y is less than 12 when Y is
less than one you will get stuck you
will be in a big trouble
instead
why don't you think in this way
you may have already noticed that the
formulas y less than one and X cubed y
plus y less than 12. appear twice
let's just call them p and Q
respectively then we could replace them
with the following proportional formulas
right as we oh no propositional calculus
is complete and decidable what is the
decision procedure the truth table of
course
writing the truth table we found that
this formula is a tautology
it does not require any Talent at all if
you do not feel that you have written
the proof with a truth table you may
want to draw a cat flea LK proof like
this
okay
you may think it is really redundant but
actually the redundantness improves from
the structural rules in this you know
figure but the
actually you cannot eliminate the
structural rules I believe
and that could be another good uh how to
say uh logic 101 or 201 assignment
so think about it
it is basically you know it it's it sets
basically P were not P so you know the
weakening or is uh the structure rules
are probably required so I'm sure
you all now agree with me how much
talent is required to prove Pi depends
on the context it Phi is a proportional
formula you just you know write it
through table or cut through a K3
it flies A first order sentence and if
it happens to be logically valid
you can prove it without Talent you just
write a cut-free LK tree
if Phi is a sentence in P piano
arithmetic
you you need talent and luck to prove it
so probably I quit you know from it and
I go to lcf if I Phi is a sentence in
the theory of real quotes filled you can
prove it or disprove it without Talent
so what exactly does it mean that real
closed field is decidable
it means that
for any lcf formula there is an
equivalent cut a quantifier free formula
that is a very elegant and short model
theoretic proof
however there is a problem with model
theoretic proofs because they are not
useful in many cases because they do not
give us any algorithms
house keys original proof theoretic
proof is very long complicated and
tiresome so I would I'm not going to
show that that house keys you know
original proof this time you know
because this is birthday party nobody
wants to read
ask it proof I believe
what's up today probably only few people
read his proof however his proof has a
great point
he gave the you know concrete algorithm
for quantifier elimination and showed
that it terminates
unfortunately the size of the resulted
quantifier free formula may be super
super exponential to the size of
original formula
again
it seems that there is a trade-off
between talent and time
but I'd like to consider why Talent is
needed when writing mechanical proofs
especially when removing quantifiers by
analyzing informal proofs
as an example let us prove the following
lcf formula
FX equals to x squared is continuous
everywhere
okay this proposition written in natural
language with a formula if x equals to x
squared could be transformed into the
following formal formula right Epsilon
data okay the word everywhere goes here
right
and the rest goes there right so four
quantifiers are contained how can we
eliminate them
okay
so the
outermost you know what you call Sim
let's quantifier is a universal
quantifier
so to eliminate
to them
actually
you have to write the the first line
the only way to eliminate it to write
let X be a real number right as the
first line of the proof
by writing this we can eliminate the
first quantifier
the next quantifier is again
uh Universal quantifier right again the
only way to eliminate it is to write
that Epsilon be
a custom real number
then we can you know
eliminate the second quantifier let us
verify this and okay okay
suppose that the outermost logical
connective of the right most formula in
succeeding is a university quantifier
by applying all all right
rule in backwards we can eliminate the
quantifier by replacing X by
eigenvaluable a in the formula B
in other words not Talent is required to
eliminate the university quantifiers in
most of the theories except for theories
of natural numbers
why are the theories of natural numbers
exceptions because
of the induction right
so the induction is represented in LK as
shown
in the lower sequence a new Universal
quantifier
which is not in the upper sequence
appears
in other words
unlike other areas of mathematics in the
theory of natural numbers where
induction is present Universal
quantifiers may be introduced by a rule
other than for all right rule
fortunately in lcf we do not have to
worry about induction so we we do not
need to wonder you know which
for all right rule or induction be
applied you know just you know
for all right rule
so
now the most outermost logical symbol is
existential quantifier
this cannot be eliminated as easily as
universal quantifiers
this is because we have to find the
witness Delta such that for all y the
for any real number why
did uh
such that the the
distance of x squared and Y squared is
less than Epsilon when the distance of X
and Y is less than Delta
so the Delta should be the volatiles uh
that
Delta should be a term of the
volleyballs we have eliminated so far
which is X and Epsilon
let us calculate Delta as mechanical as
possible
find the witness okay so the distance
between x squared and Y squared must be
less than Epsom right so by applying
triangular inequalities and stuff like
that you know we we have this inequality
then solve it in Sigma in terms of Sigma
then we have this this is so
the right most the the term minus X Plus
square root of x squared plus Epsilon
can be the witness per Sigma
so
we we probably will
we will notice that we cannot eliminate
X from this wetness so that means f x
equals to x squared is not uniformly
continuous everywhere
so
that is how it works in natural proof
let's also check with LK to see why
removing an existential quantifier does
not go
the same way as universal quantifier
okay
this one
here you see exists right rule in okay
if you look at the upper sequence the
term T appears instead of an eigen
variable in other words you have to find
the witness to apply exist right or for
all left rule in backwards in LK
so if you wish to write proof without
any Talent you may have to try every
term in ascending order of ghetto number
or whatever
again
it seemed that there is a trade-off
between times
so I began to think about what would
happen if I let the words least math
talented but fast as the calculator to
solve alcia problems
that was the reason why I started an AI
project can I AI pass the entrance exams
of the University of Tokyo in 2011.
with Advent of chat GPT there are no
many attempts to get AI to take College
exams
but when we started our project in 2011
that is 12 years ago no team anywhere in
the world third it would be possible
I remember that when the New York Times
reported on our project in 2013 14 the
article made pessimistic prediction
nevertheless
Pony wrap the paper and took it to the
Department of computer science and said
hey look Noriko made it into the New
York Times
I love that episode it's right Tony how
lovely
usually mathematical you know problems
written in natural language with some
mathematical expressions like this one
even if the problem can eventually be
interpreted as an lcf form problem it is
difficult to rewrite it directly into an
lcf formula
the natural interpretation of the
problem should be a higher order formula
like this one
right
this required the interpretation still
required a huge dictionary with by hand
we had to teach our AI 2000 mathematical
axioms in 8 000 Japanese words to make
it accept the problems written in
Japanese
next it is converted into lcf formula it
is already very lengthy
I hate to read then
our AI starts solving the problem using
the latest quantifier elimination
algorithm to get the answer
okay
a fully automatic Mass following machine
has been a dream since the birth of the
word artificial intelligence
but it has stayed at the level of
arithmetic for a long long time
another project we finally succeeded in
developing a system
which solved the pre-university level
like this one
from n to n
I'd like to show you a demo but I'm not
quite sure it moves in Zoom
is it is is it moving
no
oh good good
if somebody cannot see online you know
please watch my TED Talk
the demo is included in my talk so now
it you know um outputed the past three
it is the you know precise how to say
interpretation of the natural language
now it is converting into the lcf
formula and
it's top no go go and Solve It Go
and it outputed
and
the following problem is obtained by
Collins quantifier elimination algorithm
okay so the answer is one half and it is
correct
the problem with this method however is
the humans cannot understand the lengthy
answers that are output
so let me first answer the question that
you will probably want to ask most
is this method is still better than big
data and the statistics and based method
like stat GPT
chat GPT team has not published any
result how well it does on math problems
so we cannot directly compare
but
we are very confident that the current
state of the art is our AI
uh an event
invented by our math team
if you are interested please read this
paper accepted last year by each car
the time left for my talk is now very
limited I really
regret that I will not be able to attend
the party celebrating Tony's birthday
that will be held after my talk so if
everybody is there
[Laughter]
thank you so in closing
I'd like to wish Tony a very happy
birthday
60th birthday and express my deepest
gratitude
for all that you have done for us and
for the academic community
may you continue to inspire us for years
to come
thank you very much and see you all some
sometime in Tokyo probably very soon
thank you very much
can you hear me hi Enrico
um so first I just wanted to say that I
love to watch you cook
[Laughter]
maybe other people
is Tony yes yes
hi you know I have a more serious
question maybe other people have the
same question
um so do you think that uh so if you
have any opinions on not the current
chat GPT but you know what what the
future is of proving yeah proving
theorems you know
with talent and with explanation
you know where there's some reflection
that the algorithm knows what it's yeah
well
I understand your worry too and um
I cannot say everything about you know
the the
future you know it's so hard to predict
right now but as long as I experienced
that the chapter GPT is what what gbd is
doing is mainly the uh the searching
so um if he cannot search then you know
he cannot come up with the answer and if
he wants to really you know prove it or
you know solve it
you it has to you know develop that the
you know semantic dictionary and the
defining axioms and it is really really
time consuming and the question is if
the the
uh the the AI can make this dictionary
by itself
not you know asking human to work
I'm not
yeah no I don't think so so probably and
and also you know that there's no other
ways than the you know 0.5 elimination
or you know
uh
other you know
the the things that we developed in
uh in logic you know there is no way to
get the answer because it is kind of
weird you know
if you see that the tedious lengthy
proves that our system produces
it's like you know like 100 pages long
and
it is
it seems to me
for the computer it is hard to say which
formula is
important which is others do not
so it cannot
you know how to say compare the
importantness of the
the limits and the formulas that the but
the
uh he cannot understand that you know
that redundant formulas versus
important formulas
can you understand what I mean you know
it
it it it seems that my AI cannot
understand the importantness of the how
to say did
are they formulas it produces so
um I don't I don't think other than
searching you know
nowadays deep learning machines can do
better than
this
and that is what I can say but I
it is really hard to predict the future
right now in AI
thank you thanks
oh thank you
thank you
um Noriko
yes hear me
yes I can hear okay this is Maria
uh Maria Maria
well I just wanted to say that you know
there's a lot of talent and in your work
you know
and uh and I miss you a lot you know I
miss you a lot too
welcome
see see see probably
you came to Hiroshima right but you
didn't come to the Tokyo because you are
so worried about the earthquake probably
but uh you know Abby and uh and Tony of
course and uh no also background and the
other words everybody came in we we have
you know kind of room for logicians any
logicians are welcome to come to my
house we our house is called logic house
okay so everybody is welcome to come
okay so Maria please come sometime okay
okay
thank you thank you
tonight
is Alistair there
Foster was online I don't know if he
still isn't lying ah hi hi Hollister uh
he couldn't come at the last moment he
was going to be yeah after here yeah
yeah I can see him yeah
I guess we can see him but you can and
that's what matters I I yeah I I could
see him that was great okay yeah I'm so
grateful
and uh who else
Sam there
I want to see Sam too if I can well I'm
here in person I'm so grateful I'm so
grateful okay thank you for the call
most of my you know the work is due to
your you know bounded arithmetic and
also that the
the the
what was that at the Kinkos copy you
know published your
lecture yeah that was my textbook thank
you very much I'm so grateful oh thank
you for the talk that was delightful
yeah thank you thank you
yeah the joke was fantastic
I came to let you go
those minus food is waiting people don't
want to let you go
thank you very much oh I have a question
so what is your favorite theorem
because I was stressing when
I was stressing when you asked the
question thinking that you were going to
want an actual answer and what came to
my mind was the completeness serum which
is pretty much what you said was your
favorite
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know I thought you know more in a
completen ethereum and cut elimination
is more positive unicorn
and just to prove it only just gave like
a two week long tutorial on completeness
here
oh that's great
I shouldn't I think you explained it
better anyways okay
thank you very much and such a warm
event
anybody
well thank you so much
thank you
see ya see you soon
bye bye thank you so much for making it
online at this ungodly hour it's 8 30 in
Jose 30 in the morning in Japan
[Music]
you did it two mornings in a row oh yes
and my fault
I say oh yeah it will be on Monday
but Japan is well ahead of the rest of
the world in case you don't know
problem no no problem I'm so sorry about
that but so good to see you
it's great yeah yeah I rehearsed
yesterday so it was good